estoy seguro de que todos habéis oído
hablar de esta entrevista para muchos la
entrevista del año tacker carlson la
estrella mediática del trumpismo ha
entrevistado bueno ha conversado con
Vladimir Putin en el mismísimo kremlin
durante más de 2 horas en visual politic
hemos tenido la posibilidad de publicar
en este canal la entrevista doblada al
español ya sabéis que somos una
comunidad enorme y que gracias a vuestro
apoyo podemos tener un alcance enorme y
recabar información y documentos tan
interesantes como este en este caso
hemos tenido dudas pero es la primera
gran entrevista que Putin ha dado a un
periodista internacional desde que dio
comienzo la brutal invasión de Ucrania
la entrevista es polémica taker carlson
hace lo que se esperaba de él no rebate
los argumentos de Putin ni tampoco hace
preguntas incisivas la sensación es que
tan solo perseguía su agenda obtener una
declaración de Putin acusando
directamente a la otan de la guerra no
lo ha conseguido con todo la entrevista
es un documento histórico nos muestra a
un líder que algunos podemos considerar
que delira pero Es evidente que de una
forma u otra es un líder que está
condicionando toda la política
internacional por eso hemos querido
dejaros aquí en visual politic la
entrevista íntegra en español para que
podáis sacar así vuestras propias
conclusiones señor presidente Muchas
gracias eh el 24 de febrero del 2022
usted se dirigió a su país cuando empezó
el conflicto en Ucrania y dijo usted
que estaba actuando porque le parecía
que Estados Unidos podían emprender un
ataque súbito contra su país Por qué
considera usted que Rusia podía dar un
golpe así súbito contra Rusia no es que
se trate de que
Estados Unidos hayan intentado o
podían hacer un golpe súbito contra
Rusia tenemos un Talk show o una
conversación seria
Ah Le
agradezco es una conversación seria eh
tengo entendido que tiene una formación
histórica de historiador Sí por eso me
permitiré entre unos 30 segundos un
minuto para una información histórica no
está en contra usted sí por favor eh
mire Cómo empezaron nuestras relaciones
o interrelaciones con Ucrania de dónde
apareció este tema el estado ruso empezó
a formarse como centralizado y se
considera el año de la
fundación del estado ruso es
862 el año eh
cuando se invitó para gobernar
al príncipe ruri de los varegos de los
Norman en en
862 y en
1862 Rusia celebró El Milenio de su
estado de su estatidad
en 18
en
862 el príncipe olek que era sucesor de
rurik que de hecho era un regente con el
hijo menor de edad
eh
destituyó a los dos hermanos que También
tenían que parentesco con ru y así
empezaron a desarrollarse dos centros en
kiev en eh
moscovia Ah otro otra fecha muy
importante en la historia de Rusia ah
eh
978 cuando el
hermano
de un sucesor de rurik empezó a
cristianizar a Rusia así empezó a
consolidarse el estado ruso centralizado
era un territorio unificado lo las
relaciones económicas unidas el el
idioma común y después de la
cristianización de Rusia una fe única y
El poder del Poder del Duque o príncipe
y así empieza el estado ruso
centralizado pero debido a diversas
causas después de que empezase la
sucesión al Trono eh la Edad Media y
lafa el sabio un poco más tarde cuando
murió eh la sucesión era un poco
eh
compleja No iba del padre al hijo sino a
los Hermanos o a los hijos otros hijos y
así se desmembró el estado Ruso
centralizado y único no tenía nada de
especial Porque lo mismo pasaba en
Europa pero el estado ruso eh
desmembrado
eh se convirtió en un botín fácil para
el Imperio de genis khá y también su
sucesor el can batu que saquearon todas
las ciudades rusas la parte rusa donde
estaba K algunas otras ciudades
Perdieron su independencia y las
ciudades del Norte eh conservaron cierta
soberanía estaban pagando eh
un un botín a
los a los deis
pero iba formándose un estado ruso
centralizado mientras que la parte del
Sur con kev empezó a tender
hacia otro imán que era el gran ducado
de lituania y Incluso se le calificaba
de ducado lituano ruso porque los rusos
eh eran una proporción
eh considerable
de esta población que eran cristianos
ortodoxos luego se
eh hundieron el gran ducado de lituania
con el reino de Polonia entonces más
tarde se firmó una
eh una
Unión religiosa y esas tierras tuvieron
que ver con el Papa de Roma pero durante
décadas se llevaba al cabo la
polonize
y ucranio
significan originalmente que estaban en
la zona limítrofes del estado y Ah De
hecho se dedicaban a un servicio de
guardafronteras no era
eh un grupo étnico especial los cosacos
Y entonces los polacos estaban
polonize
a esta parte de de las partes rusas de
las tierras rusas que empezaron a luchar
por su
independencia escribiendo eh cartas a
Varsovia para pidiendo
ah
eh Me he perdido un poco En qué años fue
esto
Eh Esto fue en el siglo xi1 en el siglo
xi más bien sí Y entonces
ahora le explicaré
eh lo que siguió para que no nos
confundamos en
1654 un poco antes
incluso las personas que controlaban el
poder en esta parte de Rusia
pedían a Varsovia
repito pidiendo
a personas de origen Ruso y cristianos
ortodoxos para gobernar y Varsovia no
les respondió y de hecho refutó sus eh
eh pedidos eh se dirigieron a moscovia
pidiendo no inventó nada eh pidiendo que
instalas en su gobierno eh
Ahora Mire le voy a dar estos
papeles no creo que usted invente algo
no no no De todas formas son copias de
documentos de archivo y son cartas de
bogdan
jmelnitski persona que controlaba el
poder en aquella parte de tierras rusas
que ahora llamamos Ucrania escribía a
Varsovia y cuando no le satisficieron
sus pedidos empezó a escribir a moscovia
a Moscú pidiendo que el sar ruso eh
les
amparas se lo dejo hay hay traducción al
ruso luego lo traducen al inglés si
quieren Rusia no quería aceptarlos y
admitirlos
porque temía una guerra con Polonia pero
un poco más
tarde el Concilio de
semst el gobierno del Estado ruso
decidió eh incluir esta parte de las
tierras polacas en el estado ruso en el
Ah las tierras del S ruso
Ah empezó la guerra evidentemente y
después de aquel pacto de 1650 cuadrados
a los a los 32 años se firmó la paz
eterna con Polonia y estas tierras todo
toda la parte la la orilla izquierda del
nier del río niper eh estuvo con Rusia y
la la orilla derecha del río niper quedó
con Polonia Rusia siguió uniendo tierras
del sur y de occidente
eh todo antes de la Revolución Ah Pero
antes de la Primera Guerra Mundial el
Estado Mayor eh de Austria empezó a
promover muy activamente la idea de ucra
isar porque en víspera de la Guerra
Mundial
había un deseo de debilitar al
eh Enemigo al adversario potencial
entonces Ah la zona limítrofe y con una
población no tan rusa como consideraban
consideraban que era un grupo étnico
especial ucrani y empezaron los teóricos
de a surgir los teóricos de la
independencia Ucrania que se referían a
la necesidad de independizar a Ucrania y
estos pilares de la independencia de
Ucrania también planteaban que
necesitaban unas buenas relaciones con
Rusia sin embargo después de la
revolución de
1917 los bolcheviques
eh tratar de Recuperar el estado empezó
La Guerra Civil incluido también eh las
hostilidades con Polonia en
1921 se firmó una paz con Polonia eh Y
la parte occidental eh en la otra orilla
del niper de nuevo se unió a Polonia en
1939 una vez que eh Polonia colaboró con
Hitler con Hitler y y colaboró con
Hitler de hecho porque Hitler tenemos
todos los documentos en el en los
archivos y Hitler eh proponía una paz
con Polonia un tratado de paz y
cooperación con Polonia pero exigiendo
que Ucrania le devolviese a Alemania el
llamado corredor pasillo de danek que
unía la mayor parte de Alemania con la
prusia Oriental y kingsberg eh después
de la Primera Guerra Mundial estea
territorio fue entregado a Polonia y
después de danek o en vez de danek
surgió la ciudad de dank
eh exigieron que se lo diesen
pacíficamente se los polacos no
quisieron y y se dedicaron a repartir a
Checoslovaquia Pero usted dice que una
parte de Ucrania
son de hecho tierras rusas durante
siglos por usted cuando llegó a ser
presidente tenía armamento suficiente
por espero tanto tiempo no lo hizo hace
24 años Sí ahora estoy terminando la
parte histórica pero es que explica
mucho eh claro No no es aburrida sí me
agrada mucho que lo valore así bien
entonces antes de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial cuando Polonia colaboró con
Alemania
Ah no quiso
cumplir las exigencias de Hitler
Ah participó en el reparto de
Checoslovaquia pero los polacos
eh obligaron a Hitler empezar la Segunda
Guerra Mundial contra Polonia o
empezando la guerra contra Polonia que
empezó el primero de septiembre de
1939 Ah y la unión soviética de
hecho se portó de una forma muy honesta
lo leí en los documentos de archivo y
la unión soviética le pidió a Polonia
una autorización
para prestar sus tropas en ayuda de
Checoslovaquia pero el canciller de
Polonia dijo que incluso si los aviones
soviéticos eh pasarían sobre el
espacio de Polonia estarían derribados y
de este modo empezó la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y Polonia fue víctima de esta
política porque
según los protocolos conocidos de
Molotov rer trop
es una parte de estos territorios
incluida la Ucrania occidental eh
volvieron a la unión soviética y así
Rusia recuperó su tierras históricas
después de la victoria en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial o como decimos la guerra
eh
patriótica La gran guerra patriótica
estos territorios fueron eh
eh considerados de Rusia ya
definitivamente Polonia recibió los
territorios
alemanes originales O sea la parte
oriental de Alemania una parte eh de
estas tierras que ahora son
tierras del Oeste de Polonia se recuperó
la salida al Báltico
eh se recuperó danek eh que se llamó gk
en polaco y así a la hora de formar la
unión soviética en 1922 los bolcheviques
empezaron a formar la urs y crearon la
Ucrania soviética que a hasta
ahora hasta aquel entonces no existía
Ah stalen existía en que estas
repúblicas que se formaban que entrasen
como
eh formaciones autónomas pero por alguna
razón Lenin el fundador del Estado
soviético insistió en que tuviesen el
derecho a salir de la unión soviética si
lo quisiesen y así
ah le dio a la República de Ucrania
soviética tierras eh por alguna razón lo
hizo tierras que no tenía nada que ver
con Ucrania En aquel
momento
integraron la parte de Ucrania incluida
toda la zona del litoral del mar Negro
que históricamente no tenía nada que ver
con Ucrania y fueron
e unidas a Rusia en tiempos de Catalina
La Grande
e incluso
Ah Si volvemos a
1654 eh tres o cuatro zonas de aquel
litoral de mar Negro Eh no tenía nada
que ver con Ucrania en 1654
Ah usted tiene conocimientos
enciclopédicos pero por en los primeros
22 años usted no se refería a esto eh
estando de presidente de Rusia eh Es que
la Ucrania soviética recibió muchísimos
territorios que nunca Nada tenían que
ver con
Ucrania territorios que recibió Rusia en
algún momento como resultado de Las
Guerras Ruso turcas y se llamaban novor
Rusia o sea la nueva la otra Rusia pero
Lenin el fundador del Estado soviético
así creó a Ucrania de esta forma y eh
durante décadas estando dentro de la urs
la República soviética de Ucrania se
desarrolló y los bolcheviques por
razones desconocidas se dedic también a
ucra
ocación
de de Ucrania también tenía que ver con
otras repúblicas
federadas públicas de la unión soviética
y también la Ucrania soviética después
de la Segunda Guerra Mundial Ucrania
recibió no solo parte del territorio
polaco que ahora es Ucrania occidental
parte de territorios húngaros y de
territorios romanos Ah o sea se le quitó
una parte a Hungría y a Rumanía que
también engrosar la parte de Ucrania
soviética y siguen estando allí Por eso
tenemos todos los fundamentos para
firmar que en
cierto sentido Ucrania es un estado
artificial creado por voluntad de stalen
o sea Hungría o otras naciones tienen el
derecho a recuperar sus tierras
eh Para volver a las fronteras de
1654 no estoy seguro de que se recuperen
aquellas fronteras de
1654 pero en los tiempos
de el gobierno de stalen se refieren a
ello con palabras de régimen estelista
eh dicen de la violación la infracción
de los Derechos eh humanos y los
derechos de otros estados o
sea tampoco se planteaba que no tengan
ese derecho de recuperar usted se se lo
planteó a orban de que puede recuperar
una parte de Ucrania jamás se lo he
dicho Jamás ni una sola vez eh Ni
siquiera hablamos con él sobre esto eh
sabemos Eh sé F dignamente a ciencia
cierta de que los húngaros que viven en
aquel territorio Claro que quieren
volver a Su patria histórica y ahora le
voy a explicar una historia personal muy
interesante
eh a principios de la década de los 80
eh salí del entonces
leningrado salí en carro eh
aif Ah fui a la ciudad de beregovo es
que todos los nombres de ciudades y
pueblos
eh ponen lo ponían en ruso y en un
idioma que no entendía húngaro O sea no
había nada en ucranio o sea Ruso y
húngaro llegó a alguna aldea
veo a unos hombres vestidos de traje muy
oficial y con e
Ah copas eh sombreros copa pregunté qué
son artistas No dijeron que son húngaros
y es tierra de ellos y viven allí
habitan allí todos los nombres todo en
tiempos soviéticos la década del 80 el
siglo pasado conservaron y siguen
conservando
el idioma húngaro los trajes típicos se
sienten húngaros y desde
luego Bueno yo creo que
hay mucho de esto
y seguramente muchos países no están
contentos con la definición de las
fronteras
tras Las Guerras de los del siglo XX y
lo que usted ha mencionado pero usted no
ha dicho nada de esto públicamente hasta
febrero del año
2022 usted decía que sentía La amenaza
física por parte del occidente y de la
otan incluida La amenaza nuclear y esto
le obligaba a actuar eh le entiendo
correctamente bueno Yo entiendo que
quizás
bueno eh estos discursos
bueno se salen de del del marco de la
entrevista por eso al principio le
pregunté si íbamos a tener una tertulia
un Talk show una entrevista una
conversación seria Así que Hemos llegado
al momento en el que se creó la Ucrania
soviética después en el 91 se eh
derrumba la unión soviética y todo lo
que eh Rusia Pues
a lo que Ucrania ha obtenido Pues de
Rusia como Don como regalo pues lo ha
agarrado y
el y estoy me estoy acercando a algo muy
muy importante Gracias Bueno de hecho el
derrumbe de la unión soviética fue
iniciado por la el gobierno ruso no no
no entiendo por qué se gobernaban Pero
cuál fue el motivo bueno hubo había una
serie de de motivos me imagino ante todo
En aquel momento el gobierno de
Rusia pensaba que la base de las
relaciones entre Rusia y Ucrania de
hecho el idioma común del 90 por de la
población habla hablaba ruso pues las
relaciones familiares y Eh pues cada un
30% o más tienen e relaciones familiares
familiares allí cultura común historia
común e incluso una religión común todo
esto es son cosas tan fundamentales
estando en el marco de a un
mismo estado a largo de eh cientos de
años y todo esto funda la base de de que
las relaciones seran buenas es
inevitable eso es lo primero y segundo
un aspecto muy importante yo quiero que
usted como ciudadano americano y sus
espectadores lo escuchen ante todo el
gobierno ruso consideraba que la unión
soviética ha dejado de existir y por eso
no hay ninguna tipo de línea de división
ideológica Rusia
voluntariamente y de de forma pues eh
Por propia iniciativa ha comenzado el
derrumbe de la unión soviética y pues
pensar que todo esto será entendido por
el occidente civilizado como una
propuesta de alianza de colaboración eso
es lo que esperaba Rusia de los Estados
Unidos y del occidente colectivo así
llamado en general había gente Eh lista
en
Alemania gombar
un actor político del partido social
demócrata que en conversaciones con los
dirigentes de la unión soviética antes
del ru insistían que era obligatorio
crear unos sistemas de seguridad en
Europa un sistema en el que va a entrar
los Estados Unidos Canadá Rusia y otros
países de Europa central pero es
importante que la la otan no sea no esté
expandiendo porque decía si la otan
seguira expandiendo Seguiremos lo mismo
que pasaba durante la Guerra Fría pero
más cerca de las fronteras de Rusia y ya
está era un hombre muy sabio pero nadie
le escuchó es más se enojó Bueno
también lo tenemos ahí pues si no me
escuchan No volveré a a venir aquí a a
Moscú otra vez se enojó con el gobierno
soviético Pero tenía razón todo pasó
como lo dijo y sin
embargo Bueno claro que sus palabras
pues se han hecho verdad y ya hemos
hablado de esto pero muchos en los
Estados Unidos pensaban que las
relaciones entre Rusia y los Estados
Unidos serían buenas después del
derrumbe de la unión soviética Pero ha
pasado lo contrario pero usted jamás ha
explicado por qué motivo ha ocurrido
esto en su
opinión si por supuesto el occidente
tiene miedo de la Rusia fuerte pero el
occidente también teme de la china
fuerte el occidente teme al a la china
fuerte más que a la Rusia fuerte porque
en Rusia hay 150 millones de personas y
en China son 1,5000 millones y la
economía de China está se está
desarrollando A pasos agigantados un 5%
al año o más y bueno para china es
suficiente entonces el bismark lo dijo
en un momento lo más importante son los
potenciales y el potencial que tiene
China es colosal es la primera Economía
del mundo desde la pariedad de poder
adquisitivo y lo está creciendo Y ahora
no vamos a hablar de de quién teme a
quién vamos a pensar en otras categorías
después del año 91 cuando Rusia esperaba
que iba a entrar a formar parte de la
familia hermana de los pueblos
civilizados no no pasó ustedes no
engañado Cuando digo ustedes no me
refiero a usted personalmente hablo de
los Estados Unidos se prometió que la
ota no iba a expandirse hacia el este y
esto ha pasado cinco horas de expansión
nosotros
e estamos pacientemente Bueno
soportándoos
una economía de Mercado ya no existe el
partido comunista vamos a llegar a un
acuerdo es más lo he dicho públicamente
bueno de voy a hablar de los tiempos de
yelsin hubo un momento en el
que pues pasó un gato negro y yelsin fue
a los Estados Unidos hizo un discurso en
el congreso
Y decía God bless America Dios bendiga
América él lo dijo por favor
dejen
acéptenlo voz en apoyo de de los serbios
y nosotros no podíamos quedarnos
callados Yo entiendo que había procesos
complicados Sí pero Rusia no podía
quedarse quieta inmutable por con lo que
pasaba en Serbia porque es una cultura
también
ortodoxa y muy cercana y lo más
importante es que yelsin se pronunció en
apoyo que hicieron los Estados Unidos en
violación del derecho internacional de
la estatuto de la ONU comenzaron a
bombardear
Belgrado los Estados
Unidos sacaron al genio de la de la
botella y que es más Rusia protestaba
y qué se contestó el estatuto de la ONU
y el derecho internacional no se han
quedado anticuados ahora se refieren al
derecho internacional Bueno sí Por
supuesto que hay que eh cambiar las
cosas pero no de este
modo pero sin embargo bueno empezaron a
decirle de todo a yelsin de que es un
alcohólico de que no entienden él lo
entendía todo perfectamente se lo
aseguro está bien yo llegué a ser
presidente en el año 2000 digo bueno el
lo de yugoslavia ya pasó hay que
intentar recuperar las relaciones abrir
esta puerta por la que intentaba
pues entrar Rusia Es más yo lo decí
públicamente lo puedo repetir aquí en la
reunión en kremlin con el presidente
saliente Bill Clinton aquí mismo en esta
misma
habitación aquí al lado yo le decía
Bill tú qué piensas si Rusia
pues quisiera llegar a formar parte de
la otan Tú crees que Sería posible él
dijo Bueno sería interesante yo creo que
sí y por la noche cuando nos reunimos en
la cena Sabes he estado hablando con los
míos con mi equipo no actualmente es
algo imposible le pueden preguntar
seguramente é le está escuchando nuestra
entrevista lo puedo confirmar jamás
diría algo así si no hubiera pasado
Bueno ahora no es posible eh era usted
sincero se habría unido a la otan a ver
yo planteé la pregunta es posible o no y
la respuesta que me dieron es un no sin
no
si no fuera sincero pues para intentar
averiguar la la postura bueno Y si
hubiera dicho que sí hubieran entrado en
la otan si hubiera dicho que sí
hubiéramos comenzado con el proceso de
aproximación si viéramos el deseo
sincero de Los Socios bueno no pasó Está
bien qué piensa usted Cuáles son los
motivos de de esto porque Yo entiendo
que usted se siente pues como apenado
porque el occidente
les hecho para atrás dónde esta
hostilidad Cuáles son los motivos qué es
lo que piensa usted Usted dijo que que
siento Pues esa amargura no es una
amargura no es una constatación de los
hechos no
somos pues eh
novios no son términos que que se
apropiados en estas circunstancias
simplemente pues entendimos que no nos
quieren ver entre uno
más vamos a buscar los puntos en
común Por qué nos dieron la respuesta
negativa pues pregunten a sus dirigentes
yo simplemente
pues puedo tener mis ideas un país tan
grande con su propia opinión y bueno los
Estados Unidos yo he visto cómo se
resuelven las cuestiones en la otan voy
a ponerle otro ejemplo con respecto a
Ucrania el gobierno
de los Estados Unidos presiona y todos
los miembros de la otan votan aunque no
les guste yo les voy a decir lo que pasó
en el año 2008 no voy a decir nada nuevo
pero ya se está debatiendo sin
embargo más tarde de diferentes maneras
Tratamos
de mantener estas construir estas
relaciones habían ocurrido Pues los en
el Oriente medio en Irak y nosotros pues
íbamos construyendo el diálogo con los
Estados
Unidos y yo en múltiples
ocasiones hablé de que los Estados
Unidos no apoyaran el separatismo y el
terrorismo en el caucaso del Norte pero
siguen haciéndolo y el
apoyo político financiero de información
incluso militar venían de los Estados
Unidos y sus satélites apoyando a los
grupos terroristas en el caucaso y con
mi homólogo con el presidente de los
Estados Unidos le comenté no puede ser
yo estaba preparado me preguntó tienes
pruebas y le dije sí Bueno me dijo Bueno
yo me yo voy a citarme me disculpo Bueno
pues
les les voy a dar en el
culete nosotros esperábamos esperamos la
respuesta pero no hubo ninguna respuesta
le digo al director de la
fsb Comunícate con los de la
Cia
Y tenemos la respuesta en el archivo La
respuesta es la siguiente hemos
trabajado con la oposición en Rusia
consideramos que es lo oportuno y
Seguiremos apoyando la oposición en
Rusia consideramos que es lo correcto
bueno entendimos que no hay no hay
conversación
Allí se refiere a la posición a usted
Por supuesto en este caso se hablaba de
los separatistas y terroristas que eh
libraban una guerra contra nosotros en
el
cáucaso Por supuesto que estaban en
oposición Eh Así lo llamaban ellos es el
segundo aspecto tercer aspecto muy
importante es la creación de la defensa
aérea de los Estados Unidos a los
comienzos les insistimos en que los
Estados Unidos no lo hicieran es más
cuando me
invitaron
el padre de Bush
Junior Pues en el océano
el el que el presidente Bush Tuvimos una
conversación
y
les propuse que los Estados Unidos Rusia
y Europa pudieran crear un sistema de
antimisiles Conjunto porque el sistema
americano pues atenta contra nuestr
seguridad Aunque ellos decían que se
está definiendo pues como en defensa de
las amenazas por parte de Irán y así se
ha justificado yo les propuse que
trabajamos conjuntamente Rusia Estados
Unidos y
Europa me pregunta si hablaba en
serio pero en serio sí puedo preguntar
qué año fue bueno no no me acuerdo pero
es muy fácil Buscar internet cuando
estuve en los Estados Unidos por
invitación de al padre del de
busel me dijeron es muy interesante y yo
dije imagínense si juntos vamos a estar
resolviendo Pues un problema de
seguridad a nivel global el mundo va a
cambiar seguramente tendremos nuestras
diferencias debates políticas y de otra
índole pero estamos cambiando el sistema
en el mundo de manera global y me
preguntaron pero hablas en serio Yo dije
por supuesto que sí tenemos que pensarlo
les dije está
bien después en este esta misma
habitación donde estamos vino el
ministro de defensa Gates el ex director
de la cía y el secretario de la
secretaría
de estado rais estuvieron aquí en esta
habitación nos sentamos a la a la mesa
el ministro de defensa anda aquel lado y
me dijeron lo hemos pensado y vamos a
hacerlo les
dije vaya pero con decepciones entonces
usted en dos ocasiones ha descrito como
los presidentes de los Estados Unidos
adoptaban unas decisiones y después sus
equipos pues e Sabotaje aban estos
decisiones sí
Exacto finalmente Pues
nos nos mandaron a al paseo bueno son
conversaciones confidenciales y no sería
correcto citarlo todo pero ah nuestra
propuesta fue denegada es un hecho en
aquel entonces entonces yo dije Bueno
nos veremos forzados a desarrollar unas
medidas de respuesta pero vamos a crear
unos sistemas que van a superar vuestros
sistemas de defensa y la respuesta fue
nosotros no lo hacemos contra ustedes y
ustedes hagan lo que quieran bueno
partimos de que no es contra contra
nosotros está bien hemos creado unos
sistemas
de
intercontinentales que superan la
velocidad del sonido y lo seguimos
desarrollando
Nosotros hemos superado los sistemas de
ataques Supersónicos a todos los Estados
Unidos y otros países los estamos
perfeccionando día a día
pero no lo hemos hecho nosotros Nosotros
hemos propuesto seguir otra ruta y nos
dejaron de lado ahora con respecto a la
expansión de de la otan hacia el
Oriente nos prometieron ni ni ni ni una
pulgada hacia eh Oriente hacia el este
Pero bueno no se dejó constatado en en
papel pues vamos a expandirlo cinco
cinco olas de expansión con toda la
Europa
Ah Oriental y e los países del Báltico y
han llegado hasta Ucrania y en la cumbre
en bucarest en el año 2008 declararon
que las puertas para la otan de Ucrania
y Georgia están abiertas ahora pues
bueno Alemania y Francia parece que
estaban en
contra pero luego como resultó el
presidente Bush y es un tipo duro un
político fuerte bueno según me
dijeron nos ha presionado y nosotros
tuvimos que pues dar al visto bueno como
estamos en la guardería o qué es esto a
qué hemos
jugando Pero quién Quiénes son a ver les
han presionado y ellos exeron no pero
bueno Ucrania no va a formar parte de la
otá bueno no lo sé en el 2008 dijeron
una cosa y por qué no van a decir que
que sí después
Bueno entonces nos presionaron pero les
van a presionar mañana y otra vez van a
decir que sí es algo de de parvulitos de
de guardería no sé cómo negociar Ahí
estamos abiertos al diálogo Pero dónde
están las garantías No hay
ninguna empezaron Pues a entrar al
territorio de Ucrania Bueno yo les he
contado le he contado cómo se iba
desarrollando este territorio qué
relaciones había con Rusia pero
ahí pues cada dos cada tres pues tiene
algún tipo de relación con Rusia y en
las elecciones en la Ucrania
soberana tras la declaración de la firma
de la declaración de la Independencia y
ahí se constata que Ucrania es un Estado
neutral y en el año 2008 se
repentinamente se le se abren las
puertas a la
otan vaya qué panorama más interesante
no es lo que habíamos
acordado Así que todos los presedentes
que llegaban al poder en Ucrania se
apoyaban en el electorado Pues con que
tenían un un trato bueno hacia Rusia no
es el sur y el este de Ucrania y era
pues muy complicado superar a a estos
ciudadanos que participan en las
elecciones porque bueno
entró vctor yanukovich y cuando ganó
tras el presidente kuchma organizaron la
tercera Ronda de votación que no está
prevista por la Constitución de Ucrania
es un golpe de estado alguien no le
gustó Pues a los Estados Unidos en el
2014 no no no no fue un poco antes tras
el presidente kuchma las llegó
yanukovich Victor
yanukovich pero sus oponentes no
reconocieron esta esta Victoria los
Estados Unidos apoyaron la posición y
iniciaron la tercera Ronda de
votación
eso qué es es un golpe de estado Estados
Unidos lo habían apoyado y así arribó al
poder el ganador de la tercera
vuelta o sea como a Estados Unidos no le
gustó organizar la tercera vuelta de las
elecciones eh que no estaba prevista por
la Constitución
eh llegó yino que se consideraba
político PR occidental eh pero pudimos
eh arreglar nuestras relaciones el
visitó Moscú También nosotros visitamos
kiev y nos vimos en una ambiente
informal eh Aunque era prooccidental
bueno no pasa nada
Ah todo iba bien
eh ellos estaban haciendo lo que querían
eh después eh viene Víctor yanukovich
después de que empeoraste la situación
al quizás no era el mejor
presidente no quiero valorarlo pero se
habló de una asociación con la Unión
Europea ah
eh cuando vimos este convenio de
asociación resultó que era un problema
para nosotros Porque para nosotros
teníamos
Ucrania el libre comercio teníamos
abiertas las los fronteras aduaneras
eh pero como resultado de esta
asociación eh abrían eh sus fronteras
para Europa entonces dijimos
eh eso no no vale eh vamos a cerrar
nuestra frontera con Ucrania eh
yanukovich empezó a calcular eh cuánto
recibiría Ucrania y dijo necesito más
tiempo antes de firmar algo eh pero
llegó hasta el maidán hasta el golpe go
de estado y fue un golpe de estado en
Ucrania pero Eh entonces Ucrania estaba
comerciando con Rusia más que con la
Unión Europea no se trata de eso Aunque
claro el volumen de nuestro comercio era
mayor eh se trata de que
eh era una cooperación entre las dos
entre la los dos territorios eh
eh
cooperbase cosas que eran básicas para
la economía ocrania
eh
Y entonces fue un golpe de estado y no
voy a detallar ahora
eh debido a Estados Unidos eh Y nos
dijeron a Estados Unidos eh que calmen a
yanukovich y nosotros vamos a calmar a
la oposición y así
se eh seguía el cause de un arreglo
político dijimos bien gracias vamos a
empezar a hacerlo pero los
norteamericanos
eh pidieron a yanukovich no usó las
fuerzas armadas ni policía y así fue el
golpe de estado en kiev eh con quién lo
apoyó claro lo apoyó la Cia una
organización como tengo entendido Ah
ah
Quiero agradecer a Dios de
que no nos
aceptaron porque es la Organización
seria según entiendo y eran los
servicios secretos y eran nuestros
oponentes siempre desde la unión
soviética es su trabajo técnicamente lo
hicieron todo o sea lograron lo que
querían cambiaron el gobierno pero
políticamente es un error colosal Y en
este caso la dirección política no hizo
lo que debía que hacer tenía que
preverlo en
2008 abrieron las puertas de la otá para
la Ucrania en 2000 14
eh se organizó El golpe de estado los
que eh Eh no querían aceptar ese golpe
de estado empezaron a perseguirlos así
crearon una amenaza a crimea
e empezaron una guerra contra donbas en
2014 usando Aviación artillería contra
la población pacífica hay
videograbaciones eh emprendieron una
operación del ejército de Gran escala y
preparaban más operaciones Y eso todo
sobre el trasfondo de eh potenciar y
asimilar militar mente estos territorios
y abriendo sus
puertas Claro que estábamos preocupados
y lo manifestamos de nuestra parte
habría sido
eh una ligereza imperdonable eh Y así
Estados Unidos nos empujaron hacia un
límite eh
que teníamos que tener en cuenta porque
eso
podía poner fin a Rusia y de hecho eran
nuestros hermanos porque una parte del
pueblo ruso que eh se enfrentó a esa
maquinaria bélica eso fue 8 años antes
del conflicto de ahora Pero qué es lo
que provocó el paso que usted dio
finalmente el conflicto fue provocado
por el golpe de estado en Ucrania Por
cierto llegaron representantes de tres
países europeos Alemania Polonia y
Francia eh y fueron los garantes del
convenio firmado entre el gobierno de
yanukovich y la oposición o sea ellos
pusieron también sus firmas pese a ello
la oposición
Ah organizó El golpe de estado y los
Estados eh aparentar de que no se
acordaban nada de que eran garantes del
arreglo
eh lo tiraron a la hoguera eh Y
eh eh esos tres garantes que en
vez de volver este proceso al campo
político apoyaron El golpe de estado
aunque no tenía ningún sentido porque el
presidente
yanukovich aceptaba todas las
condiciones porque no no tenía
eh ninguna posibilidad de ganar las
elecciones anticipadas para que el golpe
de estado para qué amenaza a crimea Por
qué empezar esa operación en donbas Eso
no lo entiendo ese fue el error de
cálculo que hicieron sí hizo su trabajo
terminó con el golpe de estado
y eh era la estrategia pero era un error
político porque claro se trataba de unos
5000 millones pero un error político
colosal eh podíamos haberlo arreglado
todo sin esas víctimas sin las
operaciones bélicas sin eh perder crimea
y no habría habido tanto derramamiento
de sangre si no hubiera habido maidán
ese golpe de estado y
eh habíamos aceptado de que después de
desintegrada la unión soviética
eh los eh fronteras debían estar
siguiendo las fronteras de las antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas pero nunca
aceptábamos Ni y aceptamos eh que se
extendiese que expande la otá y siempre
decíamos no lo hagan no lo hagan y de
hecho el pistoletazo
de hecho de los últimos sucesos eh fue
el siguiente primero la dirección de
Ucrania actual eh declaró que no quería
cumplir con con Los
acuerdos que después de 2014 en Minsk se
un plan de arreglo Pacífico en donbas
pero el canciller de Ucrania toda la
dirección de Ucrania Incluso el
presidente declararon que no les
gustaban esos acuerdos de Minsk que no
lo estaban cumpliendo y
eh los dirigentes de Alemania de Francia
hace un año y medio dijeron lo dijeron
Honestamente en público de que estaban
firmando los acuerdos de Minsk eh firmo
pero nunca querían cumplirlos es que nos
estaban
engañando pero usted habló con el
secretario de estado con el presidente
quizás
Ah les decía a usted que si seguían eh
bombeando esos armamentos ustedes
actuarían siempre lo
avisáis de Estados Unidos de los países
europeos para que se sase este proceso
enseguida para que se cumpliesen los
acuerdos de Minsk de hecho hablando eh
eh No sabía cómo podíamos hacerlo hay
muchos elementos para cumplir con esos
acuerdos porque hay muchos elementos
para la independencia de donbas de sus
territorios
eh estoy seguro pero Estoy totalmente
seguro y pensaba Yo sin sinceramente que
si podíamos convencer a aquellas
personas que vivían en donbas eh Para
que volviesen al Estado ucranio pero
poco a poco iban a cicatrizarse las
heridas y cuando los territorios se
integras en a la economía común cuando
empezase a recuperarse los subsidios
sociales pagasen las pensiones nadie lo
quería todos querían con la fuerza
militar resolverlo todo pero no podíamos
permitirlo y todo llegó hasta esa
situación cuando en Ucrania eh
anunciaron no vamos a hacer nada y
empezaron a preparar las hostilidades
ellos empezaron la guerra en 2014
nosotros tenemos el objetivo de Cesar
aquella guerra no la habíamos empezado
en
2022 fue un intento de terminar aquella
guerra eh ustedes lograron acabar con la
guerra lograron ustedes sus objetivos
no hasta ahora no hemos alcanzado
nuestros objetivos porque uno de los
objetivos es dentificar desna ificar o
sea prohibir toda clase de movimientos
neonazis es uno de los problemas que
estuvimos debatiendo discutiendo en el
proceso de negociaciones que terminó en
istambul a principios del año del año
pasado pero
eh terminó por nuestra iniciativa porque
los europeos nos decían que se tenía que
crear
condiciones para la firma definitiva del
documento mis colegas en Francia en
Alemania decían Cómo crees que van a
firmar un
convenio un acuerdo con la pistola en la
100 tenía que apartar las tropas cuando
apartamos nuestras tropas de kiev
enseguida nuestros negociadores ucros
tiraron al basurero todos los acuerdos
de istambul y se prepararon para una
confrontación bélica eh a largo plazo
con el apoyo de Estados Unidos este fue
el desarrollo de la situación ahora cómo
está eh eh perdón
mi ignorancia Qué cosa es la desn
ficación Qué significa a eso quería
referirme Precisamente es un tema muy
importante
desna una vez lograda la independencia
de
Ucrania Ucrania empezó a buscar como
dicen algunos analistas de occidente a
buscar su identidad y no encontró Nada
mejor que poner como la piedra de esa
identidad a los falsos Héroes que
colaboraron con
Hitler ya me he referido a
que a principios del siglo 19 cuando
empezaron los teóricos a surgir los
teóricos de la independencia la
soberanía de Ucrania partían del hecho
de que la Ucrania independiente tenía
que mantener buenas relaciones muy
buenas relaciones con Rusia pero debido
al desarrollo histórico y debido a que
cuando esos eh territorios estaban
integrados en Polonia se persiguió tan
cruelmente a los ucros y se trató de
eliminar esa identidad lo tenían en la
memoria del
pueblo y cuando empezó la Segunda Guerra
Mundial parte
eh de esta
diríamos
así de esta élite con ánimos
extremamente nacionalista empezó a
colaborar con Hitler pensando que Hitler
les traería la
libertad las tropas alemanas las tropas
de la SS hicieron el trabajo
sucio estaban eliminando a la población
polaca a la población eh hebrea eh Y
daban ese trabajo sucio a sus
colaboradores de ahí fue eh el matadero
de la población
polaca hebrea eh personas como bandera
sevich son muy conocidos y estas
personas se convirtieron en Héroes
nacionales Este es el problema y siempre
nos dicen el nacionalismo y el nacismo
también lo tiene otros países Eh sí
verdad hay brotes pero los están
presionando en otros países y en Ucrania
no Y si los convirtieron en Héroes
nacionales en Ucrania eh erigen
monumentos a ellos están en las banderas
están eh sus nombres coreadas por las
multitudes con antorchas como en la
Alemania nace y son personas que habían
aniquilado a polacos hebreos rusos hay
que terminar con esa práctica esa teoría
desde luego cualquier nación había
crecido y Ah yo digo Son parte del
pueblo ruso común Ellos dicen no somos
un pueblo aparte pero no sobre una pase
del nazismo tiene ese derecho pero no
con el nazismo el presidente de Francia
eh satisfaría el territorio que ya
tienen ahora no no no pero usted
preguntó sobre el tema del neonazismo la
desnazificación
llegó el presidente Ucrania al Canadá
esto se conoce muy bien pero en
occidente se está callando y le
presentaron en el parlamento canadiense
a una persona que como dijo el
presidente del parlamento que combatió
durante la Segunda Guerra Mundial contra
los rusos quién combatió contra los
rusos en la Segunda Guerra Mundial
Hitler y sus y su camarilla o sea esta
persona se aclaró de que él sirvió en
las tropas de la SS que mataba a los
rusos a los hebreos a los a los polacos
Entonces el presidente de Ucrania se
levantó junto con tod el parlamento del
Canadá y y eh aplaudió junto con ellos a
esta persona Cómo podemos
imaginarlo el propio presidente de
Ucrania que es hebreo
étnico Bueno en realidad tengo una
pregunta si Hitler l muerto 80 años la
Alemania nazi ya no existe y usted dice
que quieren pues Apagar esta esta llama
el nacionalismo ucraniano Pero cómo
hacerlo
bueno es una
cuestión bastante complicada le voy a
decir lo que pienso no se va a ofender
usted Pues claro que sí Bueno es es una
cuestión sutil Bueno la verdad es que me
inspira un poco algo de asco usted dice
Hitler ya ya no estado 80 años verdad
pero su su azaña está allí la gente que
ex terminaba a rusos polacos y judíos
hebreos pues
y están allí y el presidente Ucrania les
aplaude a gente así en el parlamento
canadiense entonces podemos decir que
hemos eliminado esta ideología Porque si
vemos lo que está pasando ahora eso es
la des nacif
cción hay que eliminar a la gente Pues
que promulga esta teoría y y la práctica
que tratan de observarlo eso es la
una ideología Pues en un país que no
controla bueno verá le parecerá raro
pero durante las negociaciones Estambul
Hemos llegado a un acuerdo ello está
todo
allí
recogido por
escrito que en Ucrania no se va a
promulgar el neonazismo
incluso recogido a nivel
legislativo parece que es algo que se
puede alcanzar en unas neg y no hay nada
humillante en este caso para a Ucrania
como un país civilizado y moderno quizás
algún estado pues tiene
permitido Apoyar
el el movimiento de de los
nazis habrá unas negociaciones pacíficas
Y por qué pues este tipo de
negociaciones de de paz no no se han
dado sí que se han
dado de hecho Hemos llegado a un estado
bastante complejo alto
de retirada de de fuerzas casi se
complicó pero en el momento en el que
retiramos las fuerzas de de kev Pues la
otra parte la parte ucraniana tiró tiró
a a la basura todas las los acuerdos
y
siguió los mandamientos de los países
occidentales europeos y los Estados
Unidos de seguir luchando con Rusia es
más el presidente de Ucrania ha firmado
un decreto de ley prohibiendo cualquier
tipo de negociaciones con
Rusia cómo vamos a poder llevar unas
negociaciones si él se ha prohibido y se
lo ha prohibido a
todos sabemos que está se están
proponiendo algún tipo de ideas sobre
unas solución pero para llegar a un
acuerdo hay que mantener un diálogo y es
no es algo
fácil
pero no va a hablar con el presidente
ucraniano va a hablar con el presidente
americano cuando ha hablado con Joe
biden por última vez bueno francamente
no recuerdo cuando habló con él usted no
se
acuerda No no tengo que acordarme de
todo tengo mis propios
asuntos Bueno pero él está financiando
la guerra que usted está librando bueno
él está financiando pero cuando eh yo
hablé con él fue antes del comienzo de
la operación militar especial y por
cierto no voy a entrar en muchos
detalles nunca lo hago Pero yo le
comenté que está cometiendo
un un grave error de magnitud histórica
apoyando todo lo que está pasando allí
en Ucrania
y empujando echando a Rusia y yo se lo
se lo he dicho en repetidas
ocasiones me voy a quedar
allí y qu Qué es lo que contestó Bueno
por favor pregúntale a usted usted lo
tiene más fácil usted es ciudadano de
los Estados Unidos por favor vaya y
pregúntale no me siento cómodo
comentando nuestras conversaciones pero
desde entonces no ha vuelto a hablar con
él desde febrero de 2022 no no hemos
hablado seguimos
manteniendo algunos contactos
bueno se acordará de que le
comenté sobre la propuesta de trabajar
conjuntamente a el sistema
antimisiles
Sí pues les puede preguntar a todos
gracias a Dios están todos sanos y
salvos el Antiguo presidente
condola sigue viva el señor
Gates director actual
de inteligencia
señor entonces embajador en Rusia eran
testigos de aquellas conversaciones si
les interesa pues lo que me contestó el
señor el presidente biden Pues
pregúntale En todo
caso Bueno
sí ahí lo entiendo pero para un
observador desde fuera le puede parecer
que todo esto
puede Conducir a una situación en la que
el todo el mundo entero está al borde de
de la catástrofe incluso pues se pueden
dar pues unos lanzamientos de misiles
nucleares Por qué no Simplemente Llamar
a biden y decirle pues vamos a
resolverlo Pero cómo lo vamos a resolver
es muy
sencillo seguimos
manteniendo una serie de contactos
por las a través de las diferentes
instituciones y yo les he trasladado si
de verdad
quieren terminar las acciones bcas
simplemente dejen de facilitarles armas
a los ucranianos y todo terminará en
unas semanas y antes de llegar a pues
unas condiciones de qué vamos a hablar
si si no hasta entonces es muy fácil
determinar todo esto Y qué le vamos a
suplicar si ustedes
pues pues vamos a
suministrar tal arma o tal arma Ay qué
miedo me da no no lo hagan por favor de
qué hablar de qué podemos hablar aquí
qué es lo que considera usted está la o
tan preocupada por el hecho de que todo
esto puede llevar a ser una guerra
global o incluso un conflicto nuclear
bueno en todo caso hablan de ello y
tratan de asustar a su propia población
sobre la amenaza rusa ficticia es un
hecho y la gente pensante los analistas
los que se dedican a las políticas de
verdad pues simplemente gente lista
entiende perfectamente que que es fake
que es una farsa se se está pues
inflando La amenaza
rusa usted se refiere por ejemplo a
la invasión militar de Rusia a Polonia o
a
letonia pues se puede imaginar unos
escenarios para que las fuerzas
militares entren a Polonia solo en el
caso de que de un ataque por parte de
Polonia hacia Rusia Por qué Porque no
nos interesa Polonia ni letonia
ni otros países para qué hacerlo no
tenemos interés bueno el argumento aquí
es que bueno ha invadido Ucrania
y tiene pues unas
pretensiones para conquistar todo el
continente y usted dice que no no De
ninguna de ninguna
manera no hay que ser un análista aquí
es simplemente ente es algo que va
contra el sentido
común entrar una una guerra global
porque una guerra global pues pone al
borde de la extinción a toda la
humanidad es
obvio por supuesto hay medidas de
contención
porque llevan un buen rato asustando a
todos mañana Rusia va a
utilizar unas
armas
tácticas nucleares no pasado mañana lo
van a hacer pero es simplemente para
sacar
de los contribuyentes de los Estados
Unidos o
europeos más fondos pues
Para
apoyar apoyar la confrontación con
Rusia para debilitar a Rusia uno de los
mayores senadores de los Estados Unidos
de Nueva York ch schumer dijo debemos
seguir apoyando
financieramente a Ucrania de lo
contrario
los soldados americanos tendrán
que pues participar en acciones bélicas
ahí cómo lo evalúa Usted es una
provocación yo no entiendo y además algo
algo barato porque por qué los soldados
americanos tienen que
eh entrar a las acciones bélicas en
Ucrania son hay escenarios de los
Estados Unidos y la gran parte pues
viene de Polonia en segundo lugar los de
Estados Unidos y el tercero de Georgia
y Realmente si quiere introducir ahí las
fuerzas regulares seguramente pondría la
humanidad al borde de un conflicto serio
global lo quieren los Estados Unidos
para qué a miles de kilómetros del
territorio nacional pero no tienen otros
asuntos de que ocupar suos tienen
problemas en la frontera problemas con
la inmigra
problemas con la deuda Estatal 33
trillones de dólares no tienen otros
asuntos tiene que lebrar una guerra en
Ucrania no es mejor llegar a un acuerdo
con Rusia llegar a un acuerdo
entendiendo Cómo es la situación
realmente entendiendo que Rusia va a
estar luchando protegiendo sus intereses
hasta el final y
entendiendo
esto regresar al partir del sentido
común tratar nuestro país con respeto
nuestros intereses con respeto Y a
partir de ahí pues buscar unas
soluciones Yo creo que es más sabio y
racional Quién hizo volar el northstream
seguramente usted Bueno yo est estuve
ocupado ese
día bueno Yo no eh
no no hice explotar El northstream Bueno
usted seguramente pues tiene el Ali pero
la cía no tiene un un aliv Así tiene
usted pruebas de que la otan o la cía lo
hicieron saben no voy a entrar en
detalles pero en estos casos siempre
dicen busquen a aquellos a quien les
interesa pero en este caso hay que
buscar no solo aquellos que está que
tienen interés sino no aquellos que lo
pueden hacer porque ahí puede haber
muchas partes interesadas pero bajar al
fondo del mar Báltico y realizar estas
explosiones
pues es algo complicado Y estos dos
componentes los que tengan interés y los
que sea capaz sean capaces de hacerlo
pero a ver no lo entiendo la verdad A
ver estoy confuso es uno de los actos de
terrorismo Industrial mayor en toda la
historia Y ustedes Pues probablemente
tienen las pruebas e sus fuerzas de
seguridad de inteligencia Por qué no Ah
ah las pone en la mesa y gana la guerra
de propagandas en la guerra de
propaganda es muy difícil ganar a los
Estados Unidos porque los Estados Unidos
controlan todos los
medios de comunicación
mundiales porque al final Pues los
beneficiarios finales de muchos de la
mayoría de los medios de comunicación
europeos son son fondos americanos Así
que entrar en esta trabajo pues se puede
hacer pero es bastante más más caro
simplemente pues
Ah Mostrar nuestras Fuentes y no
llegaremos a los resultados es más Los
analistas Americanos lo dicen
abiertamente Sí pero la
cuestión Usted trabajó en Alemania
se se conoce los los alemanes saben que
sus socios de la otan pues lo hicieron Y
por supuesto ha afectado un un golpe
fuerte a la economía de Alemania porque
entonces los alemanes No dijeron nada
sobre esta cuestión Bueno a mí también
me
preocupó me
sorprendió pero los dirigentes actuales
de Alemania no se rigen por los
intereses de Nacionales sino por los
intereses del occidente
porque de otra forma es muy complicado
explicar la lógica de sus acciones o la
falta de acciones porque no aquí no
hablamos del northstream
uno que han explotado pero el
northstream 2 lo han lo han han dañado
la tubería pero se puede abrir la
válvula y suministrar el gas se puede se
puede arreglar Pero no lo hacen hay otra
ruta a través de Polonia ahí pues hay
un una posibilidad de suministrar el gas
Polonia ha cerrado la
tubería pero están obteniendo
Pues los el dinero de los de los fondos
europeos y el mayor donante es Alemania
Aunque Polonia haya cerrado la ruta
hacia Alemania para qué Yo no lo
entiendo
Ucrania a qui les ofrecen le suministran
dinero y
Alemania hay dos dos rutas dos
gasoductos que pasan por Ucrania y los
ucranianos simplemente pues lo cierran y
ya están abran la segunda tubería y
pueden obtener gas de Rusia y por qué
los alemanes dicen a ver les damos
dinero les damos armas simplemente abren
la válvula y estamos comprando el gas
licuado en Europa tres veces más caro
está
e llevando al nivel cero nuestro nivel
de competitividad de nuestros
productos si si nosotros les les damos
dinero de allí ayúdenos a sobrevivir no
lo hacen pregúntales a
ellos Ese es el el sonido que tiene que
tiene la cabeza porque no tiene sentido
a ver quizás el mundo se está dividiendo
en dos hemisferios uno con la energía
barata tall otro con la energía cara
quiero preguntar sobre esto e es un
mundo multipolar por lo por lo visto
puede usted explicar Cuáles son las
alianzas a ver usted dice El mundo se
divide en dos hemisferios e el cerebro
humano está dividido en dos hemisferios
uno responde por la creatividad otro
pues por los eh procesos de cálculo pero
es una misma cabeza eh el mundo tiene
que estar Unido que la seguridad sea una
única y no apostarlo todo por por ese
millar de oro y en este caso el mundo
será estable y pronostic pero mientras
la cabeza está dividida en dos partes
pues es una enfermedad es una enfermedad
muy seria muy grave el mundo está
pasando por este periodo de una
enfermedad muy seria muy grave pero yo
creo que
e también gracias a
al periodismo Franco y no a los médicos
se podrá ligar todo esto de alguna
manera Bueno voy a poner un ejemplo el
dólar americano ha unificado a todo el
mundo en gran
medida
Y qué considera usted desaparecerá el
dólar Como una moneda de reserva De qué
manera las sanciones ha cambiado en
lugar del dólar en el
mundo
sabe
uno de los errores estratégicos más
graves de la dirección política de
Estados Unidos de usar el dólar como una
herramienta de la política
de exterior y su lucha
Ah dólar es la piedra angular del del
poderío de Estados Unidos porque por
muchos dólares que imprimas Ah siempre
el mundo los USA la inflación de Estados
Unidos es mínima un 3% 3,4 por
eh Pero ellos siguen imprimiendo sin
cesar el
dinero y Y esta es la deuda de Estados
Unidos 33 trillones de dólares y sin
embargo es el arma principal para
mantener el podero de Estados Unidos en
cuanto la dirección política eh tomase
la decisión de usar el dólar eh de
Estados Unidos como una herramienta de
la lucha política
eh fue asestado un golpe a ese poderío
norteamericano no quiero usar ninguna
expresión literaria pero fue un gran
error y fue una gran estupidez incluso
entre los eh aliados de Estados Unidos
están reduciendo sus reservas en dólares
eh porque buscan las formas de
defenderse de protegerse Porque si
Estados Unidos usan medidas como
restringir los pagos en dólares o
congelar los activos Eso provoca una
gran preocupación en el mundo entero qué
es lo que pasó
eh un 80% aproximadamente hasta antes de
202 do el 80% de nuestros pagos
en eh Exteriores en el comercio exterior
estaban en dólares de Estados Unidos en
euros y el dólar pues eh le correspondía
un 50% y ahora había quedado un 13 por
solamente pero nosotros no fuimos los
que prohibimos el uso del dólar tampoco
esperábamos a ellos los mismos Estados
Unidos habían adoptado ADO eh esa
decisión de limitar restringir las
transacciones en dólares eso es una
total estupidez eh contra los intereses
de los propios Estados Unidos de sus
contribuyentes y está socavando el
poderío de Estados Unidos actualmente
en
nuestros eh pagos antes estaban en yuan
chino
eh en torno a un 3% ahora un 34 por de
nuestras transacciones eh exteriores
eh se paga en rublos y un 34 por más o
menos en dianes chinos Por qué los
Estados Unidos hicieron esto pensaban
que iba a desplomarse todo pero nada se
se desplomó eh además algunos otros
países incluso los productores de
petróleo ya empiezan
a a llevarlo los pagos eh Por el
petróleo en johanes chinos alguien
entiende estad Lo que están haciendo
eh lo que todos los expertos
preguntenselo a
cualquiera persona inteligente en
Estados Unidos qué cosa es el dólar en
Estados Unidos lo están matando ellos
mismos lo están estrangulando Yo creo
que es una valoración justa otra
pregunta
Ah
quizás ustedes cambiaron
una potencia colonial por otra menos
peligrosa quizás pero bricks por ejemplo
estará dominada por china esto
eh es una amenaza para su soberanía
conocemos muy bien esos espantajos eh
somos vecinos con china ah no se elige a
los vecinos como tampoco a los
familiares tenemos una frontera común de
1000 km
eh Y luego llevamos muchos siglos de
convivencia coexistencia con
ellos y eh la política exterior de China
siempre Busca un compromiso lo estamos
viendo eh china no es agresiva y otra
cosa siempre nos dicen Ah
ah tratan de explicar ese espantajo Pero
sigue siendo un espantajo el volumen de
cooperación con china está creciendo
pero los ritmos de eh crecimiento de
cooperación de china con Europa es mucho
más altos que con Rusia pregúntaselo a
los europeos no temen esto O quizás lo
teman pero tratan de entrar en el
mercado chino cueste lo que cueste
porque están enfrentando problemas
económicos y las empresas chinas están
eh asimilando el mercado europeo acaso
hay pocos empresarios chinos en Estados
Unidos
Eh sí las decisiones eh políticas eh
tienden a a a restringir la cooperación
con china pero lo están haciendo para
perjudicarse a ustedes mismos eh Es una
esfera muy sutil y no hay soluciones
lineales fáciles
eh Por eso
eh introducir sanciones ilegítimas según
la carta de Estados Unidos antes de ello
piensen bien
eh las personas que están tomando las
decisiones hace un minuto dijo usted que
el mundo estaría mucho mejor si no
habría dos
alianzas compitiendo Pero quizás la
administración estadounidense actual
está contra ustedes quizás el próximo
gobierno estadounidense después de Joe
biden quiera
eh recuperar los vínculos con ustedes
quiero terminar con la con el tema
anterior 200,000 millones de
dólares que nos planteábamos con el
presidente
si el volumen de nuestro comercio con
china habíamos
soberado este tope y ya tenemos
230,000 millones de dólares de comercio
con china según los chinos llega hasta
240,00 millones y además está muy bien
equilibrado nuestro comercio está
eh complementado También en las
tecnologías de punta en la energía en
investigaciones científicas en cuanto a
brig desde ese año Rusia preside
bricks y
entonces los estados brick tienen un
desarrollo muy
rápido un ritmo muy rápidos eh si mal no
recuerdo en
1992 la proporción de los grandes siete
países en la economía mundial constituía
un 47
por
en 1992 y en 2022
y había bajado hasta un 30 poco más de
30% eh la porción de los estados bricks
en 19 992 eh era solo del
16 y ahora eh tienen una proporción
mayor en la economía
eh global que g7 Y eso Será Inevitable y
seguirá siendo como el sol que nace
todos los días Eh Y nadie puede pedirlo
eh
Y quieren adaptarse ustedes con las
fuerzas con las sanciones con los
bombardeos con el uso de las fuerzas
armadas esto es una autosuficiencia eh
Es que la élite política de ustedes no
entiende que el mundo está cambiando
objetivamente por circunstancias
subjetivas y hay que tomar las
decisiones correctas oportunas y muy
sabias eh Incluso si quieren una
dominación pero esas acciones burdas
hacia Rusia hacia otros países
eh cosechan un resultado contrario o
Eh me ha preguntado si viene otro
dirigente no se trata el dirigente no se
trata de la persona concreta yo tuve
buenas relaciones con bus por ejemplo y
yo sé que le presentan a Estados Unidos
como un aldeano Villano que no medita
bien no razona bien Creo que
Ah ha cometido muchos errores con
respecto a Rusia como en
2008 esa decisión en bucarest para abrir
las puertas de la otan a
Ucrania también fue durante su
presidencia pero en general teníamos un
nivel eh humano de relaciones muy bueno
o sea él no es más malo que cualquier
otro político americano ruso o europeo
igual que otros con Trump teníamos
buenas relaciones no se trata la
personalidad de líder se trata de los
ánimos que reinan en las elitas en la eh
sociedad norteamericana predomina la
idea de dominar cueste lo que cueste
basándose además en eh acciones de
fuerza Eh no cambiaría nada pero si se
dan cuenta de que el mundo está
cambiando por circunstancias objetivas y
hay que adaptarse a tiempo eh a estas
circunstancias cambiantes para conservar
las prioridades las ventajas de de
Estados Unidos eh sería otra cosa Ah la
economía china all en el poder
adquisitivo es la primera Economía del
mundo habiéndose adelantado a la de
Estados Unidos y son un líder global con
1000 500 millones de habitantes eh luego
Japón Rusia está en el quinto lugar
mundial porque el año pasado Rusia pesa
a todas las sansiones restricciones se
convirtió en la mayor economía de Europa
las sanciones e las restricciones eh nos
desconectaron de Swift eh la
imposibilidad de pagar con dólares las
sanciones contra
nuestros buques contra nuestros aviones
sanciones en todo se nos aplica pero nos
hemos convertido en la primera economía
de Europa las herramientas que usa
Estados Unidos no funcionan hay que
ponerse a pensar qué es lo que están
haciendo
si concienci se concienci eh las élites
gobernantes eh si se dan cuenta de ello
Entonces sí la primera persona del
estado actuaría
es orientándose lo que esperan de él los
electores y así se aportarían las
personas que toman las decisiones en
diversos niveles
eh pero usted describe los dos sistemas
de los líderes si se toman en cuenta los
intereses de los electores y algunas
decisiones de la clase gobernante eh Son
dudosas usted que dirige este país
durante
eh muchos años con esa experiencia quién
Toma las decisiones en Estados Unidos es
que Estados Unidos no sé es un país muy
complejo eh conservador por un lado
cambia muy rápidamente por el otro eh
Quién Toma las decisiones en las
elecciones hay que ver en cada estado
concreto eh pueden separar a cualquier
persona de las elecciones esas
elecciones de dos niveles
eh que es bastante complejo y no es
fácil hay dos partidos que dominan los
republicanos los demócratas y en marcos
de este sistema de partido hay centros
que toman las decisiones que preparan
las decisiones además mire por con
respecto a a Rusia después de
desintegrada la unión soviética se llevó
a cabo una política totalmente errónea
no basada en nada la política de presión
expansión de de la otá el apoyo de los
separatistas en el caucaso la creación
del sistema de defensa antimisiles todo
eso fue presión además llevar a Ucrania
a la otá también es presión Por qué
Porque creo yo que se habían creado las
capacidades de producción excesivas
durante eh la confrontación con la unión
soviética había muchos centros muchos
especialistas
eh especial I ados en la unión soviética
y no sabían hacer otra cosa y pensaban
que tenían que seguir eh golpeando a
Rusia eh lograr que se descomponga Rusia
creando eh varias formaciones cuasi
estatales y usar
eh esta separación
e para
eh usar este potencial con en su lucha
Futura contra China para acabar con ello
debe haber fuerzas frescas y nuevas que
vean bien el futuro y entiendan lo que
está pasando en el mundo 600 millones de
personas
eh Indonesia por ejemplo
eh que es una realidad y estarán en el
club de los líder de las economías
líderes del mundo eh nos damos cuenta
entendemos que Estados Unidos pesar
todos los problemas económicos de todas
formas
eh tiene una situación normal un
crecimiento de la economía como un 25%
del crecimiento del pib eh si mal no
recuerdo pero si se asegura el
futuro hay que cambiar también el
enfoque de cómo hay que cambiar Qué cosa
hay que cambiar porque el mundo cambiará
De todas formas antes de que terminen
los sucesos en Ucrania el mundo está
cambiando y hay que entenderlo y los
propios expertos en Estados Unidos están
escribiendo que poco a poco Estados
Unidos están cambiando su postura en el
munda los mismos expertos propios de
ustedes lo están escribiendo si será
doloroso o no depende de ustedes es que
eh lo escriben las personas que son no
no son
antiamericanistas están viendo las
tendencias globales en el del desarrollo
en el mundo nada más y ven el futuro
analizan la política y recomiendan
ciertas
decisiones para la
dirección y tengo que preguntarle Usted
dijo claramente que la expansión de la
oton ha sido la violación de las
promesas Y eso una amenaza contra su
país pero antes de que mandar las tropas
a Ucrania
en la conferencia de seguridad el
vicepresidente de los Estados
Unidos ha apoyado las aspiraciones del
presidente de Ucrania a entrar en la
otan y
usted pues esto provocado las acciones
bélicas insisto en repetidas
ocasiones hemos propuesto la solución de
los problemas que han surgido los
problemas en Ucrania tras el golpe de
estado en el 2014
por medios pacíficos pero nadie nos
escuchó es
más los dirigentes de Ucrania que que
están bajo el control total de los
Estados Unidos de repente declaró que no
van a cumplir los acuerdos de Minsk
porque no les gusta nada allí y
siguieron su actividad militar en ese
territorio y además las fuerzas de la
otan bajo diferentes pretextos de
formación de nacional pues eh se estaban
preparando allí y en Ucrania declararon
que eh
e adoptado una ley de que
los rusos Pues no son una nación titular
principal y y eh a la vez limitaron los
derechos de estos pueblos en Ucrania de
repente Pues declararon
que en los territorios del sur y de de
oriente
Pues los rusos no no tienen cabida allí
y todo esto conjuntamente pues ha
llevado a la decisión
de terminar la guerra que comenzaron los
Ne nazistas en Ucrania en 2014 por la
vía bélica Usted cree que zelenski tiene
Libertad para desarrollar las
negociaciones para resolver este
conflicto
No lo sé Bueno
hay hay dificultades es difícil de
juzgar pero
mi
padre
estuvo en guerra contra los fascistas
con nacista durante la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y yo he hablado con él y me
decía Vladimir qué haces estás apoyando
loses en Ucrania mientras t tu padre
pues
eh estuvo en en guerra contra el
fascismo en en el frente y
y bueno no voy a decir lo que me
contestó es un tema aparte no creo que
es lo lo correcto pero realmente bueno
es cuando llegó al poder él pensó que no
es mejor no entrar en conflicto con los
neonazis con Los ultras y además el
occidente liderado por los Estados
Unidos está siendo apoyado y seguirá
apoyando a todos aquellos que
ah Están en conflicto con Rusia es algo
provechoso y Es algo seguro a pesar de
las promesas a su propio pueblo de
terminar la guerra en Ucrania ha
engañado sus propios
electores pero considera que ahora
en febrero de
2024 tiene libertad de hablar con su
gobierno tratar de ayudar a su país de
alguna manera o lo puede es algo que
puede hacer él por su cuenta pero por
qué no se considera Pues el dirigente de
estado ha ganado las elecciones Aunque
en Rusia consideramos que todo lo que
pasó después del año
2014 la fuente de ello fue un golpe de
estado y en ese sentido Incluso el pador
de ahora pues es bastante
eh defectuoso pero se
considera presidente lo conoce en los
Estados Unidos toda Europa y Bueno de
hecho casi todo el mundo no Por qué no
Si eh hemos eh estado llevando las
negociaciones con Ucrania en Estambul
Hemos llegado a un acuerdo y él lo sabía
no además el dirigente del grupo de
negociación el señor aramia Yo creo que
él
eh sigue liderando pues la fracción del
partido gobernante eh del partido del
presidente en la rada el parlamento del
país Él sigue estando allí en el
parlamento y además ha dejado su firma
en este documento del que le habló y él
mismo
públicamente
declaro estábamos listos para firmar
este documento Pero llegó el Sr
Johnson el Primer Ministro de Gran
Bretaña y nos dijo que era mejor entrar
una guerra y en este caso pues no nos lo
van a dar todo en caso de un conflicto
bélico contra Rusia
y aceptamos esta esta propuesta
véanlo lo dijo
públicamente su
declaración pueden volver a esto lo
quieren o no pues Y a partir de ahí el
presidente de Ucrania
ha adoptado un decreto de ley que
prohíbe las negociaciones con nosotros
lo va a cancelar no nosotros no nunca
hemos renunciado a las nego
estar rusi lista por supuesto que sí
pero ellos públicamente lo han
renunciado que cancelen su decreto y
comienza las negociaciones y el hecho de
que hayan accedido a los requerimientos
de el ex Primer Ministro de Gran Bretaña
señor Johnson pues es
algo triste porque como dijo el señor
aramia hace un año y medio podíamos
haber terminado estas acciones bélicas
de terminar esta guerra pero los
ingleses nos convencieron Y renunciamos
a esta decisión Dónde está Ahora el
Señor Johnson y la guerra
continúa es una buena pregunta qué
piensa usted para qué lo
hizo quién lo va a saber yo no lo
entiendo Así estaba la situación todos
tenían la ilusión de que nos pueden
derrotar en el teatro bélico pues de
sobre
confianza quizás de puro corazón pero
por falta de de mente de
conciencia usted describió la conexión
entre Rusia y Ucrania descrito a Rusia
que es un país ortodoxo ha hablado de
esto Qué significa para usted Usted es
un líder de un país cristiano cómo usted
mismo se describe Qué efecto tiene esto
sobre
usted bueno como yo ya he mencionado en
el año
988 El Conde
Vladimir
cristianizó siguiendo El ejemplo de su
de su abuela la conesa Olga y después
pues todo todo su su su su grupo y en
unos
años cristianizó toda toda Rusia y es un
proceso
de de los paganos a los cristianos es un
proceso que ha llevado sus años pero al
final es el
cristianismo
Oriental se ha enraizado y Rusia
siempre ha sido muy leal hacia la gente
que sigue otras religiones islam budismo
judaísmo y ahí está la fuerza de de
Rusia sin lugar a dudas porque en todas
las religiones mundiales de las que he
hablado que he mencionado que son
religiones tradicionales de la
federación de Rusia de hecho las tesis
principales los valores principales son
muy similares por no decir las mism que
son las
mismas todo ello bueno y los las
autoridades de Rusia Siempre han tenido
mucho respeto han tratado con mucho
cuidado la cultura y la fe de aquellos
pueblos que entraban a formar parte de
el Imperio de Rusia porque es la base de
la seguridad y estabilidad de Ah la
soberanía de de Rusia
Porque todos esos pueblos lo considera
Rusia Su patria porque por ejemplo en
América Latina
pues la
gente de Europa pues vienen de Su patria
histórica acaban en Estados Unidos o en
Europa y la gente
que pues siguen sus
religiones consideran Rusia Su patria no
tienen otra y somos una gran familia y
los valores son tradicionales como he
dicho es una gran familia pero cada uno
tiene su familia y es la base de nuestra
sociedad Y si hablamos del hecho de que
la patria y la familia
pues es algo que está muy ligado entre
sí es así porque no es posible
garantizar un futuro para los hijos para
las familias si no garantizamos un
futuro estable para todo el país para la
patria por eso en Rusia el Patriotismo
es tan
fuerte si me lo permite las religiones
son diferentes de hecho el
cristianismo es una religión no agresiva
porque Cristo dice ponle otra mejilla no
mates y demás y De qué modo un líder
puede ser cristiano si hay que matar a
alguien Cómo se puede conciliar muy
sencillo si hablamos de la defensa de su
propia
familia Su patria nosotros no atacamos a
nadie como comenzó lo que está pasando
en Ucrania con el golpe de estado y con
el comienzo de acciones en donbas con
esto y nosotros estamos protegiendo a
nuestras gentes a nosotros mismos
nuestra Patria y nuestro futuro con
respecto a la religión en general no es
algo que se manifiesta Pues
en lo externo no esir a la iglesia cada
día o darse golpes contra suelo de
cabeza está en el corazón la cultura que
tenemos está orientada al ser humano
dostoyevski muy conocido en el occidente
como un genio de la cultura rusa de la
literatura
rusa ha hablado de esto del espíritu
ruso porque la sociedad occidental es
más pragmática el hombre
ruso piensa más en lo eterno sobre los
valores
morales éticos quizás no esté de acuerdo
conmigo pero la cultura occidental es
más
pragmática y no digo que sea algo malo
esto da la posibilidad
del millar actual llegar a pues una
serie de logros en la producción en la
ciencia no hay nada malo en esto
Simplemente digo que nosotros pues
tenemos un aspecto similar pero la
conciencia está estructurada de de una
manera algo
diferente entonces usted considera que
hay algo sobrenatural que está actuando
cuando ve lo que está pasando en el
mundo o ve las obras de Dios en lo que
ve eror dice que hay pues algunas
fuerzas sobrenaturales aquí no
francamente
no no pienso de esta manera pero yo creo
que la
comunidad internacional pues se
desarrolla siguiendo sus propias leyes y
Son como
son y siempre ha sido así en la historia
de la
humanidad algunos pueblos y Estados
países pues
se levantaban se multiplicaban se
reforzaban después bajaban del Olimpo en
la calidad a los que estaban
acostumbrados quizás no no hay que poner
demasiados ejemplos empezando Pues de
las conquistas Pues de eh chingis Khan
terminando Pues con el gran Imperio
Romano parecía que no había nada tan
grandioso como el Imperio Romano pero el
potencial de los bárbaros se iba
acumulando y bajo sus golpes se derrumbó
el Imperio Romano porque había más y y
empezaron a desarrollarse bastante bien
como decimos ahora pues económicamente
empezaron a ser fuertes estables y el
régimen que se había impuesto por el
Imperio Romano eh haba derrumbado bueno
tardó 500 años en derrumbarse este
proceso Pues de
descomposición tardó 500 años la
diferencia con la situación actual es
que los procesos de cambios de Ahora son
bastante más rápidos que en los tiempos
del Imperio
Romano Pero entonces cuándo comenzará el
Imperio
de la Inteligencia
artificial
bueno parece que estamos entrando en
unas cuestiones cada vez más
complicadas para contestar esto por
supuesto Hay que ser un especialista en
el ámbito de los grandes números en el
ámbito de la Inteligencia artificial hay
muchas amenazas que atentan contra el
ser
humano los estudios en el ámbito de la
que pueden crear pues
al ser humano con capacidades especiales
el hombre especializado el hombre
Guerrero El el científico el deportista
ahora y lo más que ya ha introducido un
chip en el cerebro de alguna
persona creo que es imposible para mosk
y
har lo
que cree necesario pero hay formas de
convencer Yo creo que es una persona
inteligente
eh Y hay que canalizar este proceso hay
que eh subar lo a ciertas reglas la
humanidad debe estar pensando ir
pensando lo que le pasará en adelante y
debido
a los nuevos logros de investigaciones
tecnologías en la genética en la
Inteligencia artificial
pronosticarlo porque cuando la humanidad
se dio cuenta de La amenaza que
presentaba el arma nuclear todo el mundo
los que poseían las armas nucleares eh
se dieron cuenta de que hay que
consensuar porque si no se llega a un
Exterminio total
eh cuando se llegue a entender que el
desarrollo incontrolado y sin límites de
la Inteligencia artificial o bien de la
genética eh o de cualquier otro H
eh cualquier otra investigación moderna
cuando la humanidad se dé cuenta de esas
amenazas
eh yo creo que llegaría el momento de
eh acordarlo a niveles estatales o
interestatales de cómo deberíamos
regularlo
eh Le agradezco mucho por el tiempo que
me ha dedicado
y quiero formularle otra pregunta
más sobre sobre Ivan gerscovich de 32
años periodista norteamericano que lleva
más de un año en prisión aquí en Rusia
es una gran historia en Estados Unidos y
Quiero preguntarle estaría usted
dispuesto como un gesto de buena
voluntad eh liberarlo para que vuelva
para que lo llevemos a Estados
Unidos hemos hecho tantos gestos de
buena voluntad que creo que ya habíamos
agotado todos los límites a nuestros
gestos de buena voluntad nadie nos ha
contestado con gestos análogos pero como
principio estamos dispuestos a hablar de
que tampoco excluimos
tampoco excluimos
que podríamos hacerlo
pero con un movimiento recíproco por
parte de nuestros socios diciendo socios
me refiero a los representantes de los
servicios especiales ah Están en
contacto permanente y están debatiendo
esos temas no tenemos ningún tabú para
dar solución a este problema estamos
dispuestos a darle solución pero hay
ciertas condiciones
determinadas que se analizan en los
canales con nuestros socios entre los
servicios
especiales tenemos que acordarlo desde
luego todo
pasa durante
siglos un estado atrapa un espía lo
detiene luego lo canjea por alguien eh
No es mi asunto analizarlo Pero quizás
no sea un espía sino un ser humano una
persona eh un sencillo niño quizás haya
infringido
eh su legislación Pero quizás no sea no
es una espía y se podría devolverlo
podríamos analizar mucho de lo que es
una espía o no lo es
eh pero hay cosas determinadas y si
alguien recibe la información secreta
sobre una base de Conspiración esto se
llama espionaje
Ah él se dedicaba precisamente a ello
recibía una información secreta
confidencial y lo hacía de una forma
oculta no sé por qué lo hacía quizás era
por su propia iniciativa por poca
cautela Pero esto se llama espionaje Y
fue pillado en fraganti
ah al recibir esta información sea
algunas cosas inventadas no demostradas
habría sido otra historia pero se
le captó se le capturó en inf fragante
cuando recibía una información secreta
eh
conspirando usted dice que trabajó para
el gobierno norteamericano para la otá o
bien era un periodista que había
recibido una información que que no
debía caer en sus manos hay una
diferencia entre esas categorías no sé
para quién trabajaba pero repito eh
obtener una información secreta sobre
una base de Conspiración se llama
espionaje No sé si
eh Y él trabajó para los intereses de
los servicios especiales norteamericanos
no creo que haya trabajado para Mónaco
eh si es que Mónaco está interesada
obtener esa información pero eh deben
dedicarse a ellos los servicios
especiales
eh Y le voy a explicarlo Ah
ah está en un país en un país Aliado de
Estados Unidos una persona que por
razones patrióticas
eh había eliminado en una de las
capitales europeas a un
Bandido Durante los acontecimientos del
cauc pasó sabe lo que hacía este no
quiero comentarlo pero lo diré
el eh tomaba a nuestros soldados
prisioneros los ponía sobre la carretera
y luego un vehículo aplastaba sus
cabezas Qué clase de persona es y si es
una persona un ser humano
eh se encontró un patriota que lo había
eliminado en una de las capitales
europeas lo había hecho por iniciativa
propia o no es otra
cuestión y luego pero
ivanovic no hizo nada
parecido es una historia totalmente
diferente es un periodista pero hacía
otra cosa repito es un periodista que
había recibido la información secreta
sobre una base
[Música]
conspirando y es otra hisoria
me refiero a una persona que de hecho
está controlada por las autoridades
estadounidenses estén donde
estén y ha un diálogo entre los
servicios especiales debe
decidirse calladamente tranquilamente
sobre una base profesional que trabajen
hay contactos no excluyo que esta
persona al que se ha referido el señor
gerscovich
porque no debe volver a su p no tiene
sentido tenerlo
eh en prisión en Rusia pero que nuestros
colegas de los servicios especiales de
la parte estadounidense que se pongan a
pensar sobre los problemas que enfrentan
nuestros servicios especiales no estamos
eh cerrados para negociaciones y ha
habido casos cuando hemos acordado y
podemos acordar entre nosotros eh pero
hay que seguir
eh negociando
Ah entiendo Espero que lo excarcel
gracias muchas gracias señor presidente
también me gustaría que vuelva a su casa
finalmente pero repito hay un diálogo
continúa y mientras más hablemos de
estas cosas en público más difícil es
resolver tales cosas
eh
hay que resolverlo con calma pero a
decir verdad eh No sé si esto funciona
con la guerra y si me permite otra
pregunta más quizás no quiera contestar
a usted Por razones estratégicas pero no
le preocupa a usted que lo que está
pasando en Ucrania puede llevar alguna
cosa de mucha mayor envergadura mucho
más terrible y se está dispuesto usted
si está motivado para llamar a Estados
Unidos y decir vamos a
negociarlo ya se lo he dicho tampoco no
hemos renunciado a las
negociaciones no hemos dicho que no es
la parte
occidental y sin duda alguna Ucrania es
un satelite de Estados Unidos hoy en día
eso es obvio no quiero que suene como
una un insulto o las malas
palabras un apoyo financiero de 72,000
millones en segundo lugar lo ocupa
Alemania otros países europeos decenas
de millardos de dólares van a Ucrania un
gran flujo de armamentos que se lo digan
a la dirección actual de Ucrania
pónganse a la mesa de conversaciones
eh
eh cancelen su decreto idiota y y
pónganse a
negociar pero a ver si usted la ha dicho
pero en realidad se ha dicho que Ucrania
Pues no ha podido firmar el la paz por
indicaciones del ex ministro de Gran
Bretaña que estuvo actuando
por control de Washington por eso le
pregunto por qué no lo resuel
directamente con la administración de
biden que controla la administración de
zelenski en Ucrania Bueno si la
administración de selenski en Ucrania ha
renunciado a las negociaciones yo parto
a la base de que la ha renunciado por
indicación de Washington
Pues si es una decisión incorrecta Pues
que renuncie a esta decisión algún
pretexto que no ofenda nadie no es
nuestra decisión es allí donde adoptaron
la decisión pues que renuncien y ya
está pero no ha adoptado una decisión
incorrecta y nosotros debemos Buscar la
salida de esta
esta decisión incorrecta corregir sus
errores si ellos es una Met pata suya
Pues que que lo solucionen nosotros
estamos a
favor quisiera asegurarme de que no le
estoy mal entendiendo usted quiere
obtener a través de las negociaciones la
resolución de aquello lo que está
ocurriendo en
Ucrania es correcto pero ya lo hemos
logrado Nosotros hemos creado un gran
momento en
Estambul
eh que fue parafinado por los dirigentes
de la
delegación
ucraniana pusieron ahí su firma en el
estrato en todo ya puso su firma y
después
dijo estamos listos para firmar pero
estábamos listos y ya habríamos
terminado con la guerra hace un año y
medio pero vino el señor Johnson y nos
nos ha hablado de que no debíamos
hacerlo y
hemos perdido esta oportunidad bueno han
cometido un error perfecto pues vamos a
volver allí Pero por qué nosotros
debemos resolver este
error sí es
un es
un
error no intensifican las el suministro
de armas y habría terminado un la guerra
que eh comenzó en el año 2014 pero vamos
a regresar más atrás vamos a volver al
91 cuando la otan nos dijo que no habría
expansión en el 2008 cuando las puertas
de la otan Se abrieron vamos a volver a
la declaración sobre la independencia de
Ucrania donde se promulgó como un Estado
neutral vamos a volver al hecho de que
las bases de la otan y las bases
americanas inglesas empezaron a aparecer
en el territorio de eh Ucrania creando
estas amenazas vamos a regresar al hecho
de que el golpe de estado en Ucrania en
el 14 fue organizado no tiene sentido
verdad Pero podemos estar pasándonos la
la pelota de un lado para otra pero si
si son ellos los que han cesado las
negociaciones un error bueno corríjalo
nosotros estamos dispuestos considera
usted que sería humillante para la otan
reconocer
el bajo el control de Rusia aquello que
hace un año era el territorio ruso ya y
lo he dicho Ah piensen en cómo hacerlo
de forma digna siempre hay opciones si
hay
voluntad hasta ahora han estado haciendo
ruido han estado gritando tenemos que
buscar la derrota estratégica de Rusia
en el campo bélico y ahora pues llegan a
la conclusión de que no es
fácil si no imposible bajo mi opinión no
será posible por definición no va a
pasar nunca y ahora pues se están dando
cuenta aquellos que están controlando el
occidente que están en el poder y si se
dan cuenta pues piensen en lo que se
puede hacer Estamos abiertos al
diálogo estaría usted dispuesto a decir
pues
la la Enhorabuena han ganado vamos a
conservar la situación tal y como está A
ver es objeto de negociación
que nadie quiere desarrollar con
nosotros o más bien quieren Pero no
saben cómo yo sé que que ellos quieren
no Solo lo veo tengo conocimiento de
claro de que quieran hacerlo pero no ven
la forma de
hacerlo pero si ellos han conducido la
situación en la que estamos ahora no lo
hemos hecho nosotros sol Los así
llamados socios oponentes está bien que
piensen en comoo Cómo dar el
giro nosotros no decimos que
no Sí sería una situación graciosa Si no
si no no hubiera Esa esa pena porque la
interminable movilización de fuerzas en
Ucrania la histeria los problemas
internos todo esto de
tarde o temprano de un lado de otro
llegaremos a un acuerdo y saben qué
incluso puede sonar algo raro en la
situación
actual de igual modo las relaciones
entre los pueblos se van a recuperar es
algo que va a llevar mucho tiempo pero
se van a recuperar voy a poner ejemplos
poco clásicos en el campo de guerra hay
un confrontamiento
un ejemplo
específico los
soldados ucranianos quedan rodeados es
un ejemplo real de las acciones bélicas
nuestros soldados les gritan no tienen
ninguna salida ríndanse salgan y que van
a conservar la vida ríndanse
y luego de del otro lado les gritan en
ruso un idioma ruso bueno los rusos
nunca se rinden murieron todos ellos se
siguen considerando rusos es en cierto
modo un elemento de una guerra civil y
todos piensan que en el occidente Pues
que las acciones bélicas han logrado
apartar los pueblos parte de los pueblos
rusos del otro
no habrá una
reunificación y la verdad es que no no
ha sido ninguna ning ninguna parte Por
qué los autoridades ucranianas están
desgarrando la iglesia ortodoxa rusa
porque está uniendo no un los
territorios sino
a el propio alma y nadie nadie logrará
desgarrar
esto terminamos aquí o hay algo
más no yo creo que ha sido magnífico por
mi parte es todo muchas gracias señor
presidente